rien. Ça on essaye de retrouver
le site pendant les grandes
années en émettant fonctionner.
Cette fois-ci les autorités ont
pensent que c'est la bonne le
reportage.
- La Place des Nations, un
des joyaux du parc Jean-Drapeau,
est à l'abandon depuis 40 ans
et dans un bien piètre état.
ROBERT BEAUDRY, responsable,
gestion immobilière, Montréal
- On parle ici d'un impact
sur le développement économique
de la métropole,
son développement culturel,
un nouvel espace dont
les Montréalais vont pouvoir
bénéficier.
- On réhabilite l'ensemble
du site à l'identique.
- Le site s'apprête à retrouver
son lustre d'antan.
Un projet de 75 millions $,
dont 46 ont déjà été confirmés
par la Ville de Montréal.
- C'est de la responsabilité
de tous les paliers
de gouvernement. On parle
vraiment du rayonnement
de la métropole. On parle
vraiment de son rayonnement
culturel, son rayonnement
touristique. On est
en contact avec les différents
ministère concernés et il y a
de l'appétit, il y a
de l'enthousiasme.
- La Place des Nations
modernisée abritera un espace
public quatre saisons,
un restaurant, un lieu dédié
à la diversité culturelle
de la métropole et un musée
consacré à Expo 67, car à cette
époque, la Place des Nations
était un lieu névralgique.
ISABELLE BONNEAU, dg, Société
du parc Jean-Drapeau
- C'était la place du peuple,
donc un lieu de rassemblement
qui pouvait accueillir 7000
personnes, donc à ciel ouvert,
magnifique amphithéâtre
et qui a par la suit été utilisé
pour Terre des Hommes, donc
pendant... Jusqu'au début
des années 80.
- Mais depuis 1981, la Place
est abandonnée et interdite
au public parce que
trop dangereuse.
MANUELA GOYA, vice-présidente,
Tourisme Montréal
- C'était un vrai péché
de le laisser à l'abandon.
Il y a quelque chose
d'exceptionnel qu'on peut offrir
aux touristes : mieux nous
connaître, mieux connaître
notre histoire, mais aussi
aux Montréalais
et se l'approprier en bonne
et due forme.
- La Place des Nations incitera
les Montréalais et les visiteurs
à découvrir ces îles
aux trésors.
- Nous avons deux trésors
inestimables que d'autre villes
ne peuvent pas avoir en :
le grand parc du Mont-Royal
et ce parc, qui est immense,
qui est exceptionnel.
- Le fait d'avoir un nouveau
lieu de destination...
- Ce projet de réhabilitation
est le premier grand projet
du plan directeur
de conservation, d'aménagement
et de développement du parc
Jean-Drapeau.
- On ramène vraiment la Place
des Nations telle qu'elle était
à l'époque, donc avec un souci
du détail patrimonial
qui va jusqu'au mobilier,
jusqu'aux drapeaux de l'Expo 67,
qui seront présents.
- Les appels d'offres
pour les plans et devis
sont lancés et l'ouverture
au public est prévue pour 2024.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, M